[Music]
dr dench looked disheveled
he had two days of stubble
he had pinpoint pupils and hardly seemed
to blink
and there was something else
dunge had a hole about the size of a
nickel in the back of his scrubs
[Music]
more sponges
there's too much blood in the field
i can't see anything more suction
future
this isn't right no it isn't we gotta
understand h you need to say something
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
should we start the cell saver doctor
focus on your job
[Music]
there's a lot of bleeding doctor we
should get an a-line kit 14-gauge iv
blood warmer maybe if i see you a head's
up
we got to get this under control doctor
we
you mean me i need to get this under
control yes doctor you need to get this
under control perhaps we bring in
vascular what's vascular going to do you
can't get the blood pressure under
control it's not an issue with the blood
pressure why don't we start there shall
we
see the disc
track
christopher dunch is an impaired
physician a sociopath and must be
stopped from practicing medicine by the
texas medical board immediately
you're prepared to file a formal
complaint absolutely yes
all right
you are going to spend his license i
mean what happens to him in the meantime
we can't do that
why the hell not the attorneys won't go
for that we'd be opening ourselves up to
a lawsuit i thought protecting the
public was the priority that's our
number one priority what's to prevent
him from seeking privileges at any one
of the other 400 hospitals in the state
dr dunch has resigned from bail she
should have been she came he no longer
has privileges at dallas medical he has
no privileges anywhere
perhaps he's taking some personal time
getting his head straight
after what was a difficult week
difficult week you know what there was a
urologist a urologist you got me accused
by a patient of fondling his genitals a
urologist these morons pursued the case
i mean this this feels like we got to
draw blood in order to move the needle
dunce was distracted give me a break
well they're not wrong
he lost privileges at two hospitals news
travels fast not fast enough
but we voiced our concern we filed a
complaint they launched an investigation
what more would you like to do i want to
break his damn hands dr kirby we have no
choice but to respect the integrity of
this process did you hear those groupers
in there the process is going to gus the
system is broken and we are a part of
that system
basically
his reaction was you're a nurse i'm a
doctor i know what i'm doing i can do it
with whatever you have on hand and just
just get it scheduled
i asked for the charge nurse yeah well
you got the chief of surgery she's my
patient her treatment is my decision
well today this is my hospital and when
you apply for privileges here you didn't
check the little red box that said brain
surgery you are interrupting an
extremely delicate spinal fusion oh i'm
so sorry i thought you called for this
i presumed that you were shrewd enough
to simply sign off well i'm just a
country hick from the bronx so let me
put this in a manner even i can
understand
we don't do craniotomies at this
hospital
and you are a guest here at dallas
medical if one of our staff tells you we
don't have privileges for a procedure it
is not an invitation for debate i have
privileges everywhere across this city
oh you do i will ensure that not a
single patient comes through your wow
that would be so true
i'm going to walk you through what's
about to happen
you will complete your work on madeline
bayer she's been open far too long you
will then transfer dorothy burke out of
your care there will be no more
discussion of craniotomies no more
arguments you will do it
and then you will get the
out of my o.r
[Music]
so you're telling me that if they had
notified the board
he
could have been stopped within days of
that these are people dying because
you're afraid of a lawsuit
oh hello what a surprise
hey amy afternoon randy
so
how can i help
you
christopher dunch
oh boy
that about sums it up
he operated on a patient at legacy
frisco a few days ago he left a hole in
her esophagus sliced her vocal cord
we parted ways with dr dunch almost a
year ago
what can you tell us about this
reference
that you wrote for dr dench i didn't
write anything well whatever law firm
you paid to write and it isn't a
reference letter it's a letter stating
there were no restrictions or
suspensions of his privileges but it
implies that there's nothing in his
record to preclude him from working at
other hospitals he he maimed people here
he killed shelly brennan by drilling
through her vertebral artery he also did
that to another patient shouldn't dad
have precluded him from employment at
other hospitals
i have to be careful about what i say
right now
oh
i feel like i'm in the twilight zone
here like i'm staring at the face of a
cover-up
that's offensive
well i'll make sure to pass on how
offended you are to his other victims
facts were disputed in some of his
surgeries here surgeries yeah i saw one
of his air quote surgeries here first
hand and yet somehow dr kirby i didn't
receive your complaint
[Music]
our letter for dr dunch is our fair and
honest appraisal of his standing at this
institution was dunch ever suspended
your litter indicates that he was under
investigation and since it's your policy
to suspend any doctor under
investigation i assume that you follow
through with your policy
yes you're correct we did
i recall it was 21 days
that's convenient
excuse me national practitioner data
bank yeah that thing established by
congress i know to warn the public and
other hospitals about bad doctors i know
you only have to report the ones that
are suspended for 30 days or more
how come you didn't report dunks to the
texas medical board
i think we're done here can i ask you a
personal question
would you let dunch operate on you
lies of omission do not make this
institution any less complicit
jerry's icu nurse said later that she
felt chris seemed remarkably unconcerned
when he would come into jerry's room
he felt that chris was keeping him in
the dark
all jerry would say to me is i want to
die kill me kill me i want to die
i hear you're having some muscle
weakness in your extremities
where are you being dumb face
i had an l4 l5 lumbar procedure right
after yours
look
jerry once you're out of my o.r your
case and care are transferred to other
hospital staff it wouldn't be
appropriate for me to leave another
patient to come see you oh they really
suck to take him out of my care
[ __ ] it
here now
what's going on
the anesthesiologist administered an
incorrect dosage this led to swelling in
your spinal cord and the quadriplegic
but you give it a week of course of
steroids you'll be better than before as
promised
okay chrissy
you say it's temporary
i believe you
i'll chill out good
hey chrissy
thanks
[Music]
why did you tell him that it's clear
from the images the swelling is not
going down i'm aware
we need to alleviate the pressure on his
spine
i want you to prep an o.r we're going
back in posterior this time are you
going to tell him no just freak out more
than he already is but he needs to sign
the consent forms i spoke to his grandma
she signed off
are you sure you want to do this
maybe dr o'connor could take over the
case
[Music]
[Music]
you